[Música]
estar contándoles una historia que pase
para la cual llegue a lograr encontrar
cuál era mi pasión verdadera mi pasión
verdadera
la descubrí con mucho sacrificio porque
porque cuando yo era niño yo me críe en
un ambiente en el cual les me decían que
la gente con talento es la gente que
sería en la tele la gente que era actriz
actores los futbolistas que ganaban el
mundial el presidente de la república y
astronautas estará la gente con talento
entonces cuando yo me di cuenta el caso
alcanzó la fama equivale el talento
pero aún así
yo seguía pensando porque se me ven
inculcando desde niño
que el talento equivalía dinero que el
dinero equivalía éxito y todos los
millonarios eran talentosos entonces no
cualquiera podría ser talentoso si no
era rico y vengo yo el día de hoy a
decirles que cada uno de ustedes es
talentoso ok talentoso en lo que ustedes
quieran hacer siempre y cuando usen el
ingrediente secreto que es la pasión y
como encontré la pasión bueno me costó
me voy a eeuu a estudiar
vengo de una familia del norte del país
mi papá
se dedica a la ganadería me decía
gustavo traza dedicarte también a eso
vas a estar 30 años en el mismo negocio
familiar dije bueno qué bueno ya tenía
mi vida planeada
lo único que yo sabía era que tenía que
hacer dinero para ser talentoso pero
como les decía la riqueza equivale a
talento entonces decidí irme a estados
unidos a estudiar y yo ya iba con con
esa mentalidad de saber que bueno yo vas
a administración de empresas porque yo
voy a administrar un negocio y voy a ser
rico va a ser millonario y va a ser
talentoso entonces voy a la universidad
pero antes de entrar a la universidad me
dicen gustavo tienes que tomar un examen
de preparación
de orientación vocacional digo bueno lo
tomo obvio voy a sacar los resultados
que yo quiero sacar y bueno así que
decido tomar la computadora 45 minutos
dándole haciendo el examen pero ojo aquí
el verdadero gustavo hiso el examen el
verdadero gustavo utilizando
sentimientos o sea parte del corazón por
más cliché que se escuche pero estando
un poco más lo que yo sentía que es lo
que me gustaba así que cuando salen los
resultados del examen dice gustavo
gustavo linares tu vas a ser bueno para
ser trabajador social psicólogo profesor
trabajar en una ong enfermero doctor
como como celeste eso ayudará a la gente
no me va a dar dinero
por más cruel que se oiga así es como a
mí se me había inculcado y a muchas
personas se les inculca desde niños que
eso no da dinero entonces dije no no no
no no gustaba esto no puede estar
pasando voy a hacer otra vez nuevamente
el examen y si nuevamente el examen y me
siento 45 minutos nuevamente pero esta
vez utilice mi cabeza mi cabeza fría la
parte norteña salió de mí entonces dije
bueno vamos a el examen y me salen los
resultados que ahora sí quería escuchar
o que pensaba que quería escuchar
gustavo linares vas a hacer un siguió
vas a ser un financiero vas a trabajar
en la bolsa de valores vas a tener mil
negocios y vas a
tener tu negocio siendo administro donde
administración de precios entonces
decido estudiar administración de
empresas iba preparado mentalmente
entonces al graduarme de la universidad
de houston
lamentablemente ocasiona algo en eeuu
que como muchos sabrán estuvo en la meca
del desempleo aproximadamente en el 2007
8 2009 10 fue cuando hubo mucho
desempleo en eeuu porque estuvo la
crisis del desempleo allá entonces me
mandó mi currículum a otros países uno
de estos países fue dubai en ese país
había dos posiciones abiertas una de
recursos humanos y otra de finanzas me
llaman aguante examen agua entrevistas y
bueno me contactan y me dicen
felicidades has quedado en este puesto
cuando voy viendo el contrato es gustavo
vas a ser gerente de recursos humanos
bueno
eso es lo que me salió en el primer
examen nos finanzas y bueno me voy estoy
joven tenía 23 años en ese tiempo me
lanzo dubai me ascienden tres veces en
dos años porque ahí fue donde me di
cuenta que el talento sin la pasión no
deja más que ser una simple virtud me
apasiona ayudar a la gente es algo que
yo ya tenía dentro de mí el ver felices
los empleados el apoyarles el ayudarles
eso a mí me daba felicidad entonces por
eso yo fui creciendo dentro de esa
carrera a los dos años me ascienden
nuevamente demandan a áfrica abrir otra
propiedad para el jeque de abu dhabi
pero
aun el diablito mal de gustavo seguía
diciendo gustavo
necesitas ser millonario necesitas hacer
lo que te salió el otro resultado de tu
examen y el angelito veneciano gustavo
sigue trabajando ayudando gente en
recursos humanos haciendo feliz a la
gente le apoyo a la población entonces
lamentablemente decidí escuchar al
angelito bueno al diablito malo y me voy
a francia a ser una maestría en finanzas
porque quería cambiar ahora mi carrera
profesional ya no quería trabajar en
recursos humanos
ahora quería ser financiero para poder
llegar a un puesto más elevado en la
bolsa de valores trabajar en watch suite
en nueva york' y ganar mucho dinero
porque recuerden yo pensaba que sólo el
talento aunque ya me había dado cuenta
que eso no era el talento
entonces decido irme
a la francia al momento de graduarme
tenía mucho miedo porque porque te acabe
había cambiado mi carrera completamente
decido regresarme a méxico después de 15
años y claro empiezo a postular a
puestos de recorte de fin de finanzas y
no de recursos humanos aunque si había
postulado un puesto de recursos humanos
en naciones unidas la cual a los 3 meses
me marcan y me dicen oye estás
interesado tenemos una vacante y tienes
que hacer un examen una evaluación pasar
las entrevistas y eso fue lo que hice
poco sabía yo que ese fue el primer
empleo que me dieron en mexico recursos
humanos nuevamente y iba a ganar menos
de lo que ganaba en áfrica y dubai y al
entrar a naciones unidas me di cuenta
que ahí donde descubrí la pasión de la
cual sigo teniendo el día de hoy y como
la describe como la podría decir pasión
equivale a que todos los días me
despierto con una sonrisa y esa sonrisa
de ir manejando el trabajo porque sé que
voy a hacer un impacto en el mundo por
más leve que es que sea el detrás de un
escritorio he hecho de todo pero aunque
sea pasaron un contrato un empleado que
va a ir a cuidar a las tortugas a los
cabos para mí eso es un impacto y el
hacer feliz a la población me fascina
entonces
fue también que dije los miedos son
sabios y hay que saber escucharlos pero
no siempre obedecer lo sé a qué me
refiero con eso claro tenía miedo el
hecho de trabajar en un lugar donde la
gente decía mi familia decía oye gustavo
tú no puedes salvar el mundo mis amigos
decían quién te crees tú no puedes hacer
salvar el mundo nadie lo puede salvar te
miente te metían miedo y claro hay que a
veces escucharlos pero no necesariamente
obedecer los por qué porque no podemos
vivir atados a un miedo a un temor
porque si no no vamos a llegar al éxito
que en realidad queremos hacer y si mi
pasión en realidad es ser
a alguien que ayude a la población es
muy mi pasión y es lo que voy a hacer el
resto de mi vida por más que tenga gente
que me diga no no debes hacer esto debes
estudiar diseño gráfico debes ser el
abogado debe ser ganadero no mi pasión
actual es recursos humanos en cualquier
organización que se enfoque a ayudar a
la población
el cual también el talento es una
consecuencia de la pasión y fue cuando
ella dije listo ya sé cuál es la
verdadera respuesta de lo que yo sentía
y lo que estuve buscando por muchos años
y no fue hasta que me llamaron de eeuu
que dijeron gustavo hemos oído mucho de
ti felicidades eres el director más
joven a nivel mundial de naciones unidas
se abre una plaza pero los 180 países
que están concursando van a concursar y
se te está invitando a ti para que
traigas ideas innovadoras yo bueno
postuló a un examen paso me llaman me
dicen gustavo quedaste tú en el puesto
el más joven a nivel mundial
y no fue
hasta que subí a esta foto en la
asamblea general en nueva york' que
empecé a recibir miles de mensajes en
instagram y otras redes sociales de
muchas personas que decían que bueno que
luches por tus sueños yo quiero luchar
por lo que me apasiona me apasiona y yo
quiero estar ayudando a la gente me
encanta ayudar a las personas que puedo
ser gustavo yo como buen director de
recursos humanos le decía están las
vacantes se tienen que postular todos
los procesos son transparentes si en
realidad te apasiona el puesto tienes
que postular a la vacante sin embargo
también había personas que me
contactaron y me decían como influencers
y me decían gustavo yo quiero colaborar
con las naciones unidas bueno sí dime en
qué puedo ayudarte
no lo que yo quiero nada más es tomar
una foto con la bandera y puedo subir
las redes que le sea bueno
si en realidad te apasiona este
hazte fotógrafa por presionarlos a no
vas a trabajar en las naciones unidas
para tomarte nada más una foto
entonces es ahí donde las personas
tienen confunden
que la pasión laboral es la que uno hace
que tu trabajo sea
hablé contigo
y por eso es bueno diferenciar lo que
hace es mejor es distinto a lo que te
busca más la pasión es ojo no fue mesero
fui a la de trabajo
y era bueno y conozco mucha gente que
hace diseño gráfico y es excelente
arquitectos que hacen mejores edificios
que cualquier persona pero les preguntó
te gusta no te apasiona no ya sea por
más tiempo
es bueno
no me gusta así que voy a dejarme con
este pensar
todos los presentes valen nada más
tienen
cómo poner la pasión en ese talento para
poder ayudar a este equipo que quiere no
importa la edad no es demasiado tarde
antes las personas personas
así que
si van a ser lo que las personas tienen
que hagan
[Música]